I can't match is at you my psycho babble
yeah we're doing field research okay
with your boy kanye right here ok gang
so let's say hey let's see here I get
hex Alec let's stay at us okay emma is
like such shitty houses and like oh [ __ ]
but like pretty dope tricity things
and
okay we haven't seen anybody in a while
maybe the monsters have stealth suits to
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] and I liked you
yeah that sounds scary
yeah okay let's get the [ __ ] outta here
ah so annoying can I go all the way
[ __ ] this way to get out Shane says
it's like we got it we got a you smug
wave okay she says I can't was just like
in one place on the Rights closer okay
here I go here we go shut God psych eval
I don't fall okay okay sneaking done
writing now [ __ ] is that I can hate this
[ __ ] over think they have good
corrosive club shut-eye passin rd
oh is that seed thing okay let me just
take this though cuz i think they have
like some of the [ __ ] has like really
good health time to fight [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] shet shet [ __ ] that
one up I see the pipe now suppose that's
all ok I got across this pipe oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] ok
here we go Ready Steady ID okay wow what
the flying [ __ ] wrong with these
people that's all okay why now hmm I
can't mr. chick oh okay
look who's back to keep get want to push
my buttons now
e
always ok thanks